[Music]
I've been doing this a long time I think
you're the first guests to walk out with
a cell phone first guess I'm looking for
something for you that I just realized
would be funny okay all right okay um so
I did like a PSA for AIDS a while ago
right
not for AIDS but you know what I mean
and to help fight AIDS yeah so my dad
saw it and I got this email from him and
I know he means that he's proud but it
was just really first the way it came
out or something let's take a look here
hold on let's see right there this is
from your dad about your eggs wonderful
so he I know what he's trying to say do
i yeah heartwarming it was heartwarming
but it didn't come out right
so aids wonderful yeah so that on a
pillow yeah
are you yeah come on you want to do
something else with the phone okay I
came up with a craft that you can do
with the phone if anyone can do it and
let's see it would take like either one
of you can do it get like turn to your
head to the side okay like this like
this and then just let your mouth be
loose and natural and maybe put but put
your lips together and put your tongue
out just a tiny bit hmm well a little
more tongue okay okay
[Applause]
now I really wish you still had the
beard
your lips are very you're not hearing
this now
going anywhere time capsules this is
your right do you realize just by doing
that on television right now how many
young people will be doing that I think
it's good I think it's good to get used
to the lady parts and not make them
shame filled things and you know oh I
another idea for girls like teenagers
girl teenagers call your girlfriend's
[ __ ] I think that's like instead of
bro because it sounds like you're
putting him down but it's it's just real
[ __ ] come on let's go go to movies
you know it's like a fun humored all
right so it's a way to empower women you
think that empowers women
I just think being comfortable and vocal
about your body is just fine I think a
lot of people agree with you I do not
I am uptight and ashamed of my body yeah
you have an app is this correct of an
app that's coming out this week I do I
don't know exactly when it's sometime
this week if you follow me on twitter
I'll say when it comes out it's called
uncle Farah and it's for babies and
toddlers and it's like way from this but
um oh yeah
babies come from the beautiful vagina on
iPhones
I really do like this I'm just um this
is therapy for me this is good yeah it's
yeah you're very you're uptight Irish
like just save vagina no I was I won't
vagina who told you to sing it
you